[Music]
what is it like seeing your baby be a
mama it's so good yeah that was good
yeah it does it's it's incredible I feel
very very lucky and blessed Kris Jenner
was beaming with pride on Monday night
come on how could she not be her
youngest daughter Kylie gave birth to a
daughter on February 1st
shortly after Kim Kardashian welcomed
her third child last month a girl named
Chicago it's overwhelming it's a lot of
little people so I love it though I
loved every second of it it's such a
blessing you tell me because I know
you're behind it how do you mastermind
keeping something like Kylie's
pregnancies
you know what I'll let Kylie answer that
okay that's her department and she did
it her way and I'm just really proud of
her life is really good right now and
it's all about the kids and the family
and just keeping everybody happy and
healthy oh is Kris Jenner as a grandmama
hi I'm a spoiler I think I'm doing yeah
I'm getting an A right now
I've decided I'm doing great and we're
also filming Keeping Up with the
Kardashians right now so season 15 is
well on its way we're about halfway
through so it's exciting it's really
exciting you decide to save things like
maybe the baby name reveal or different
things for the show and say let's put
that in the show and then other things
are for social media it just it they we
film everything and we try to show as
much as we can in 44 minutes once a week
kind of went at horse show so we try to
get in there as much as we can that we
know that everybody will love and it's
just so good
et caught up with the reality star at
the Jeremy Hotel in West Hollywood where
she attended her pal Rachel Zoe's
fashion show I've just always been a
huge fan of Rachel's and it was always a
dream come true I would always used to
watch her show thinking I want her to
dress me one day so this is kind of a
dream come true
[Music]